hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds I'm
a property investor and I get a massive
kick a buzz of helping other people
become property investors as well so in
this video here's what's gonna happen
I am going to go through some common
questions are being asked the last video
that I did Q&A Sunday last week I've had
so many questions people have been
posting great questions so I'm gonna
answer some questions but here's the
thing if you want to know anything about
property investing or property in
general comment your questions below
next week I'm gonna do another video
just like this where I'm gonna be
answering your questions so comment
below comment below comment below also
if I'm answering someone else's question
and that gives like an offshoot to
another question feel free to comment
that as well
thoughts comments below do that if you
want me to do more videos like this
please do give me some encouragement by
smashing that like button and the more
you like the more you interact the more
content I will keep putting out there so
let's see what we've got we've got an
gongs gaming blacksmith mouse and so
many questions should I focus on one
area or should I look all over my state
okay I would probably recommend
blacksmith Nelson focusing on one
particular area at a time you only want
to invest in an area that you know the
area you did you market research and if
you found an area that works really well
I would just dominate that area buy as
many properties you can do case studies
joint venture raise finance dominate
that area and then maybe one day if the
market changes or the prices begin to go
really high you can then refinance or
sell those properties and move into a
different area because if you're just
doing you know house here a house here a
house they're all over the place
it can become a logistical nightmare
happen having management on all these
properties because sometimes managing a
property manager can be as difficult as
managing tenants whereas if you've just
got one area you can really take the
time to do you research onto the area to
put a good management company in place
and get that passive income that you
need however don't think that the area
that you invest in needs to be close to
your house it doesn't it just needs to
be somewhere that makes money so that's
kind of my answer hope that helps what
else have we got Red Rooster Red Rooster
says I've caught two previous major
house booms - price stagnation
drop periods we're in the longest
stagnant price market for years it seems
do you see that that breaking and
another period of steady rise happening
again when we start yes I do I think
that wherever there's a recession it
will always follow an expansion and an
expansion will also always follow a
recession everywhere it tends to in
Britain anyway everywhere tends to
follow London so London we saw 2008
property prices absolutely crashed they
were they bottomed out around about 2010
2011 everyone was saying oh my gosh how
she's dropping so low yeah and they were
all selling their houses dirt cheap but
then what happened is in 2011 in London
they picked up in fact they'd just pick
up they shot up from 2011 to 2017
property price using lots of areas in
London they doubled over those five
years and then in 2017
they then dropped again now they're a
bit stagnant my prediction is probably
they're going to continue to go down
there's going to be things that happen
there are things that going on within
the UK changes people are a bit scared
property prices will drop a little bit
lower but at some point over the next
few years they will rise again and
everywhere follows that pattern so I
mean if you go as far as some places
like Liverpool property prices in
Liverpool are only just beginning to
pick up now they're still only just now
recovering from the 2008 crash so it
really just depend on where you are
everywhere is almost God's own little
mini economy going on inside of the
greater economy in the same way as the
UK is just a bubble of an economy when
you compare it to the global economy but
yeah if you want to make money and
capital appreciation just buy when
property prices have dropped most people
when property prices drop they get
scared yourself
whereas what successful people do and
successful investors do is they wait
until they drop and then they buy and
then they wait for it to go high and
then they refinance because if you
refinance you're not going to pay tax on
the money and then you can reinvest it
tax efficiently so that's what I'm doing
myself hope that helps great question if
you're enjoying this smash the like
button also if you like oh my gosh and
you've never got a question all of a
sudden ask your question and I will
answer as many as I can on the next time
they video guns gaming says hey Samuel
quick question does a VEVO have a
dynamic
so it recommends you the best price for
the season and changes it on all
platforms
Airbnb booking.com etc if not are there
any other good channel managers that
have dynamic pricing for rent to
serviced accommodation yes Aviva do I
think you pay a tiny bit extra for the
privilege and they can actually advise
you and guide you want exactly how much
to charge and to be honest it's
absolutely brilliant now tell you you
know depending on the season they'll
also look out for special things events
and they'll guide you on how much to
charge per night and to be honest I
think I think it's like a hundred pound
a month to get that advice from them but
it's so worth it when you take into
account that the average rent to
serviced accommodation rent to read deal
gives you between seven and thirteen
hundred pounds a month I mean most of my
students that do ready to rent we've
serviced accommodation they'll become
financially free just from two deals
sometimes they put down as little as
like two thousand pounds to secure the
deals so I definitely pay the extra
service a vivo do that and I believe
most channel management companies do as
well so I can't say for all of them but
I know you've asked about a VEVO
whenever you go the answer is yes okay
Joanne Smith hey can you do an interview
with Graham Stefan yeah
Joanne I'll happily do an interview with
Graham Stefan and I have seen some of
his videos I do know who he is we
disagree on a few things but then other
stuff we agree on what I'd say is if you
want if you know who Graham Stefan is
he's from the States
he's an investor big different from me
but I'm very happily doing YouTube
collab with him just go on through his
videos and just troll all of his videos
and say hey can you please let Samuel
Leeds interview you on his channel
I happily having on my channel I'll
happily jump on his channel just troll
him everywhere and I'm sure he'll give a
give in buckle under the pressure that's
what I usually do if you want to see me
interviewed by someone or if you want to
see me interview someone just keep
commenting it and if I see lots of
people commenting meet this person meet
this person meet this person I just go
meet the person so if you want to see on
their channels just put Samuel Leeds in
all the comments and I'm sure Graham
will love me for saying that I've seen
can we have paid off a house and
interested in buy to let adding value
and refinancing what type of mortgage
shall I go for okay so if you're going
to buy a house with the view to
refinance it shortly after you can do
that pretty much immediately as soon as
you've added value best kind of
all inch to get is probably not a
mortgage at all I'd probably get a
bridging loan or just use cash because
if you're going to buy a house and then
quickly refinance it and pull all of
your cash out the problem is if you get
a mortgage on the house in the first
place they'll usually fix you in for
like a couple years at least and then
when you refinance if you do it too
early they'll they'll charge you a
penalty fee so the best way if I was you
actually in your situation obviously I
don't know your exact situation but if
you've got a paid off house I would
refinance that paid off house on a
normal mortgage like a residential
mortgage or whatever the kind of
mortgage you need refinance it you'll
probably pay like three percent interest
on that so you've got this money now
that you're paying three percent
interest but with that money
buy a house for cash and value with the
cash that you've got and then refinance
get a new mortgage and you'll pay three
percent on that and then do it again and
just keep growing your portfolio that
way they'll be my advice okay last
question
Jamie baths and I've been to your crash
course and studied many other property
legends thank you for over the three
months now quit my job congratulations
dude I don't know if this is a question
I think this might be more of a
celebration I'm now currently going
through the preparation to create a
really creative service accommodation
experience cheers pal I'll buy your beer
one day and then literally put his phone
number
wall dude on open man in fact oh oh I'll
call this dude right now I'll call this
dude right now and just congratulate him
okay he has no idea that I'm phoning him
he may not answer this is what happens
when you comment
hey so Jamie Jamie Samuel Leeds what's
up it is bro hey do I just I'm just
doing the Q&A Sunday and I noticed that
you dropped a comment and I wanted to
congratulate you on quitting your job
you're welcome so you know so you
enjoyed the course I'm excited I'm
looking forward to getting a beer with
you one day you need just drop me a drop
me a message I'll get one of the team to
give you a call to see how we can work
together I'm sorry oh I'm a job as a
mist or Instagram I'll get one of the
teams to give you a call okay so welcome
man there we go that's the kind of thing
that happens when you when you comment
on the on the video below drop your
comments questions thoughts smash the
like button subscribe and I'll see you
next time
[Music]